Etiopía tiene un problema de imagen. Durante
años, este gigantesco país, el segundo más
poblado de toda África con casi 100 millones
de habitantes, fue sinónimo de pobreza extrema,
hambre, enfermedades, guerras… en definitiva….
de auténtica miseria.
Sin embargo, amigos, con el nuevo siglo…
todo empezó a cambiar….
Aunque Etiopía sigue siendo un país muy
pobre, durante la última década este país
se ha convertido en una de las economías
de mayor crecimiento, no solo de África sino
de todo el planeta.
Al mismo tiempo, se ha convertido en un país
muy cercano a Pekín y, también, en un estrecho
aliado de Estados Unidos en la lucha contra
el terrorismo.
[¿Por qué tener una sóla amistad si puedes
tener las dos?]
El caso es que es muy probable, amigos, que
estemos presenciando, ni más ni menos que
el nacimiento de toda una futura potencia
africana… y ese es un motivo más que suficiente
para que aquí, en VisualPolitik, no queramos
perdernos que está ocurriendo en un país
al que ya muchos comienzan a denominar como
la “nueva China africana”. Atentos.
Tras décadas de tensión, hostilidad y enfrentamiento
- antes y después de que Eritrea se independizara
de Etiopía en 1993 - este pasado 9 de julio
de 2018, ambos países sellaron la paz.
Y, ojo, porque durante todo el largo tiempo
que duró el enfrentamiento entre Etiopía
y Eritrea se vivieron momentos y acontecimientos
tan trágicos como el conflicto militar que
entre 1998 y el año 2000 sesgo la vida de
casi 100.000 personas.
Ahora en cambio, los líderes de los dos países
han acordado firmar una paz completa:
(“Hemos acordado reanudar los servicios
de nuestras compañías aéreas, conseguir
que nuestros puertos funcionen, hacer que
nuestra gente comercie y abrir nuestras embajadas
de nuevo. Ya no hay frontera entre Eritrea
y Etiopía porque un puente de amor la ha
destruido". Abiy Ahmed, Primer Ministro de
Etiopía)
Pero… claro, la pregunta que podemos hacernos
es… ¿Qué ha cambiado para que ahora de
repente estos dos países se quieran tanto
?
Pues, amigos, aunque pueda parecer increíble
uno de los problemas que ha impedido la reconciliación
ha sido esta aldea que veis en la imagen,
Badme, un lugar donde no hay prácticamente
nada de nada.
(Y es que... veréis, conforme a los acuerdos
de paz que se negociaron en Argel en el año
2000, para poner fin a la última guerra,
este territorio le corresponde, le pertenece
a Eritrea… pero digamos que el gobierno
etíope al final se dio cuenta de que no estaba
por la labor así que las cosas se quedaron
encalladas… hasta este preciso momento.)
Ahora, Etiopía, el país con diferencia más
fuerte de los 2 [Al fin y al cabo hablamos
de 100 millones frente a poco más de 5] ha
decidido ceder…
[Y es que, amigos, en muchas ocasiones eso
de empecinarse con ganar por ser el más fuerte,
es un error, a veces este tipo de conflictos
son malos para todos. No hay nada que ganar
y sí mucho que perder.]
En cualquier caso esta paz es un buen reflejo
de los cambios que se están produciendo.
Atentos porque puede que os llevéis alguna
sorpresa.
¿UN MODELO A LA CHINA?
En los últimos años Etiopía se ha convertido
en una de las economías con mayor crecimiento
de todo el planeta.
Durante la última década, Etiopía ha promediado
un crecimiento medio de alrededor del 10,
del 10% cada año.
Atentos, por ejemplo, al siguiente gráfico.
Aquí podemos comparar el crecimiento del
PIB per cápita de Etiopía con el de otro
de los países que más está creciendo del
mundo: Vietnam. [Y ojo, porque el crecimiento
de la población de Etiopía es enorme…
y aquí hablamos de PIB per cápita]
Pero.... un momento, no se trata solo de la
economía. Cómo os podéis imaginar todo
este crecimiento ha tenido también importantes
consecuencias sociales.
[Qué es algo que tarde o temprano siempre
ocurre cuando un país crece, se abre al mundo
y hace bien las cosas]
Desde el año 2000 la esperanza media de vida
ha crecido en 13 años; el número de trabajadores
con al menos la educación secundaria completado
ha crecido casi un 50% y la pobreza…. bueno…
fijaos qué está ocurriendo con la pobreza.
Sí, lo sabemos, aun hoy hay muchísima pobreza
en Etiopía. Con una simple búsqueda en Google
podremos encontrar situaciones terribles en
este país… pero es que, amigos, hablemos
claro, superar la pobreza no es algo que suceda
de la noche a la mañana… [Ojalá fuera
tan fácil]
(Addis Abeba, la capital del país, es un
buen reflejo del proceso que está experimentando
Etiopia. Las grúas, las obras y los proyectos
de todo tipo inundan la ciudad. De hecho,
fue aquí, en esta ciudad donde en 2015 se
inauguró el primer metro ligero de toda el
África subsahariana)
Pero claro, llegados a este punto… la pregunta
que a la que nos enfrentamos es clarísima:
¿Cómo diantres Etiopía ha logrado semejante
salto económico?
Pues… amigos, podemos decir que este país
se ha convertido en algo así como el alumno
aventajado de Pekín.
Por así decirlo, la
apuesta de crecimiento ha tratado de copiar
en gran medida a la del gigante asiático.
Fijaos, por un lado, el gobierno de Etiopía
ha impulsado la construcción de gigantescas
infraestructuras imprescindibles para el desarrollo
del país.
(Hablamos, por ejemplo, de la línea de ferrocarril
de más de 4.000 millones de dólares que
conecta Addis Abeba con el puerto de Djibouti
- para facilitar la exportación de mercancías
- o la mayor obra de toda África: la Presa
del Renacimiento;
una gigantesca presa en el río Nilo cuyo
inversión se acerca a los 6.000 millones
de dólares y que tiene como misión revolucionar
el sistema energético del país con electricidad
abundante y barata.)
[Por cierto, ¿Sabeis quien ha puesto la pasta
y el conocimiento para estos proyectos? Pues
seguro que a los que seguís habitualmente
VisualPolitik no os sorprende. En gran medida
ha sido China, las empresas chinas... ]
(De hecho, China se ha convertido en el mayor
inversor y en el mayor socio comercial de
Etiopía. Es decir, gran parte de todo el
crecimiento que el país ha tenido se ha producido
gracias a sus lazos con China.)
Segundo pilar, poco a poco las grandes empresas
públicas comenzaron a operar con bastante
autonomía y a gestionarse como si fueran
empresas privadas.
Este es el caso, por ejemplo, de Ethiopian
Airlines, la aerolínea de bandera del país…
que se ha convertido en la mayor aerolínea
africana y que ahora se propone competir a
nivel internacional con las grandes del sector.
(“A pesar de que ETHIOPIAN AIRLINES es 100%
de propiedad del estado, se dirige como un
negocio: la Junta dirige la empresa como si
se tratara de British Airways o United Airlines",
Zemedeneh Negatu, Presidente de Fairfax Africa
Fund)
Y por último, el tercer pilar: la atracción
de inversión extranjera directa mediante
el desarrollo de zonas económicas, incentivos
fiscales, financiación participativa, etc,
Fijaos cómo han evolucionado las inversiones
extranjeras:
De esta forma es como Etiopía ha comenzado
a industrializarse… En gran medida por todas
estas políticas y también por el coste de
la mano de obra, una industria que ha crecido
mucho en los últimos años ha sido la textil.
De hecho, marcas como H&M, Guess, Tommy Hilfiger
o Calvin Klein ya producen algunas de sus
prendas en este país.
Sin embargo… Desafortunadamente, aquí no
termina todo. Las similitudes con China no
se limitan solo a la parte económica.
( Al mismo tiempo que el país ha vivía todo
un despegue económico… la represión de
las libertades civiles se hizo cada vez más
y más fuertes: se cerraron medios de comunicación,
se persiguió a la oposición política, se
bloquearon páginas web, etc, etc.)
Durante los últimos años este país se convirtió
en uno de los 10 mayores carceleros de periodistas
de todo el mundo. Prácticamente el gobierno
de Etiopía encerró, forzó al exilio o intimidó
a casi todos los periodistas independientes.
[Vamos, en otras palabras, que prácticamente
se llegó a una situación en la que en Etiopía
no había periodistas sino portavoces del
gobierno.]
Pero… amigos, esperad un momento… porque
ahora, de repente, parece que todo ha empezado
a cambiar. Atentos.
UNA NUEVA GENERACIÓN
A principios de 2018 Etiopía estaba sumida
en una ola de violencia,, enfrentamientos
raciales y represión política tan dura que
la estabilidad del país parecía apunto de
venirse abajo.
(Además, aunque económicamente las cosas
han funcionado bastante bien en los últimos
años, también se han producido algunos desequilibrios:
una deuda extranjera no precisamente pequeña;
una gran escasez de divisas como consecuencia
de las grandes inversiones y cómo la población
crece muchísimo, un desempleo juvenil bastante
alto.)
[Vamos, que muchos se preguntaban si lo vivido
por Etiopía en los últimos años no había
sido más que un espejismo.]
Sin embargo, contra todo pronóstico… tras
una dura lucha de poder… el partido gobernante,
el Frente Democrático Revolucionario del
Pueblo Etíope - en la práctica el partido
único - eligió como Primer Ministro a Abiy
Ahmed, un exoficial del ejército de 42 años.
No se esperaba nada… pero en tan solo unos
meses….boom ¡cómo han cambiado las cosas!:
Fijaos, desde que llegó al poder, Abiy Ahmed
ha puesto en libertad a muchos presos políticos;
ha pedido disculpas por los abusos del gobierno;
ha denunciado a altos cargos de los servicios
de inteligencia y de las fuerzas de seguridad
por haber cometido terrorismo de estado;
ha impulsado el acuerdo de Paz con Eritrea;
ha anunciado una modificación de la Constitución
para establecer la limitación de mandatos
y ha comenzado a desmontar la censura política
y a pedir a los periodistas exiliados que
regresen a casa.
(“Etiopía desbloquea 264 páginas web y
canales de TV” AFRICANEWS)
Y no solo eso, también ha anunciado que el
gobierno va a profundizar en la liberalización
de la economía para atraer más inversiones
al país.
(Etiopía abre las puestas al mundo con un
plan de privatización sin precedentes. Wall Street Journal)
Claro que… como os podéis imaginar, tantos
cambios… no han sentado nada bien a muchos
miembros de la élite del país…y la respuesta
no se hizo esperar.
(Un muerto y 156 heridos en el atentado contra
un acto del primer ministro de Etiopía. EuropaPress)
El pasado 23 de junio de 2018, durante un
acto político en el corazón de Addis Abeba
en el que el presidente vestía una camiseta
de Nelson Mandela, hubo quien trató de poner
fin a esta especie de “transición política”.
Sin embargo, fallaron… y ahora el Primer
Ministro parece tener muy claro que tiene
que pisar el acelerador.
Etiopía, amigos, sigue siendo un país muy
pobre y con muchos, pero que muchos problemas….
políticos, sociales y económicos.
Sin embargo, el que un día de no hace mucho
tiempo fue considerado el país más miserable
de la tierra hoy parece tener una oportunidad
para despegar ¿Lo conseguirá? Solo el tiempo
podrá contestar a esta pregunta. Desde luego
aquí, en VisualPolitik, estaremos muy atentos
a los acontecimientos.
Si te ha resultado interesante el vídeo dale
a like y no olvides suscribirte a VisualPolitik
para estar al tanto de todas nuestras novedades.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.